on approximately efficient bilateral
claims
can you hear me
so thank you for the introduction uh i'm
coming from
i got my phd from dxcs and i'm going to
join stanford uh zero group as a postdoc
so
my research is mostly in computational
economics and more specifically in the
areas of social choice auctions market
design information design
and my research usually provides
approximations in the style of
competitive analysis on
various economic objectives such as
efficiency fairness or revenue and so on
so today i'll be talking about the joint
work with yandong jamingmo and
balochivan research
and the topic is on bilateral trade so
we look at the following standard
balancer trade model where we have sally
who is selling one item to bob
and bob has a private value on the item
this b is drawn from a distribution f
and sally has a
private cost c drawn from a distribution
g
and we assume the distributions f and g
are public information but the realized
value and cost are private to the agents
and we assume even g are independent
and in this setting we assume steli and
bob are strategic utility maximizers and
the goal is to design a mechanism with
good social efficiency so that's the
classical bilateral setting
and the first question is how do we
measure efficiency and it turns out
there's a classical notion called
transform trade
so imagine if the item goes from steady
to bob when bob's value is v instead is
constant c then the society has a hole
against b minus c
so we can say the gains from trade is
just the expectation of v minus c times
the probability of trading between b and
c
so that's the gains from trade
and in order to maximize this consumer
trade we want the trade to happen when v
is higher than c and we want the trip we
want the trade not to happen when v is
less than c
and that gives us the benchmark uh cut
the first best so it's simply the
expectation of v minus c times when v is
higher than c
and
we can also define the second best
and the second best considers the
constraint that the buyers and the
seller are strategic so we want the
mechanism to be incentive compatible and
individually rational and and also by
the balance setting so they are all
natural constraints on a reasonable
mechanism
and uh we can actually ask the question
are these notions the same
and it turns out they are not so by the
celebrated results by marissa and center
street in
1983
they show that sometimes the second best
is strictly less than the first test
and one sufficient condition for that to
happen is simply when f and g are
supported on intersecting intervals and
they have positive densities on the
intervals
so
now we know that second best can be
strictly less than first best we can
still ask the question that can we give
a constant approximation to the first
best
so concretely
do we know if first best is upper
bounded by a constant time second best
and it turns out the particular question
was mentioned in several previous works
and there has also been other works on
the special cases of this problem
and
in our work we
give the following characterization that
the second bias is
is at least 10 of the first test and in
particular we show the following simple
mechanism of randomly delegating the
pricing power to sally or bob
guarantees the ten percent of the first
best transfer trade
and so for example if we delegate the
pricing power to sally sally knows her
realized cost and also the better
distribution of bob so she can set the
price to maximize her profit in that
case
so that's our result of this paper
and since i still have time i'm
going to talk about another interesting
open question arrest in my research
so uh it's
we have voters and i'm candidates
where each voter either lacks or
dislikes each candidate
and a solution is a committee uh
consists
consisting of a subset of candidates
and in our setting of voters utility on
the committee is the number of
candidates
in that committee that she likes so the
number of elements in that subset that
she likes
and the question is is there always a
set in committee
so that for any k and any sk committee
queue
so that
there are at most k management voters
strictly preferring q to p
so a methodology ends here and we can
take some time to
for questions or
yeah thanks for the talk and the nice
open question um
so the question was some asking for some
idea about how to get the ten percent
approximation
so the proof is actually very short and
there's
there's no like concrete technique in
this verb it's more of just a
like simple algebra
but like the problem is probably not
very simple but we don't really have a
concrete technique for this
[Music]
so for example
you say randomly is that 50 50 do you
need to be smarter about it
and it's still ten percent
you're an upper bound on the ratio
some other work
which is a lower value
so about 1.36
for
the gap between first last and second
best and for our mechanism the current
best gap is 2.02
okay
can you provide a bit of intuition on
why us and the net negative result on
the from 83 um
so
like okay if they're interest if the
intervals uh intersect uh then it's
impossible but if even if it doesn't
intersect
intuitively it could be impossible right
because maybe a trade doesn't happen
because they're both trying to go over i
think there's some mechanism
like we can just say the mechanism
specifies the price
so that
the there will be a trade if the value
is higher than the price and the cost is
lower than the price oh they'll try it
and they trade that's right
okay
maybe i'll ask a question so any context
or motivation for your open problem
oh yes so um
the open problem is about uh
fairness in the
context of committee selection like
social choice
so it's related to the core incorporated
game theory so we can look at the
question so it's basically saying
we want the solution to be fair to any
subset of voters so that for any subset
of voters they cannot find a better
solution on themselves
by using their proportional voting power
so that's the idea of this open question
and we actually have some related
like for example we can give a constant
approximation to this thing but we don't
know if that actually exists
okay great any final question
very quick question on this is this
related to hedonic game theory methods
for finding
partitions of people given
people's set of
uh
like preferences of our people they'd
like to be in the same community with or
is entirely different methods
is this related to the hedonic game
literature
where you're trying to find equilibrium
partitions
given everyone's preferences of who they
would like to be grouped with for
example they like or dislike each
candidate or maybe it's a related method
i was just wondering uh i'm actually not
very familiar
maybe we can chat after yes
but it's uh for example if the solution
can be fractional then it will exist
because of some
uh economic equilibrium
thanks great thanks
any other questions
okay if not let's thank all the speakers
of the session for really illuminating
talks and
[Applause]
so we'll break for lunch now and we'll
resume at 2 o'clock